also ich glaube was wir jetzt erlebt
haben und was viele ja fast alle
europäer schockiert ist wie fragil
dieses europa ist auch dass wir uns
verlassen haben also ein europa in dem
einfach krieg bürgerkrieg politische
gefangene foltern nicht mehr denkbar
seien sollten erlebt dass autokraten
ohne gruppe europäische große städte wie
kiew bombardieren und die frage ist
jetzt reagieren wir darauf mit den
richtigen schlüssel
lernen wir wie wir unsere institutionen
besser verteidigen können gegen
korruption dagegen dass spitzenpolitiker
aus europa von putin und anderen
autokraten kurz nach amtsantritt
angestellt und bezahlt werden wie
reagieren wir darauf dass institutionen
wie der europarat unterwandert wurden
von russland erpresst wurden und immer
klein beigegeben haben wie reagieren wir
darauf dass wir in unseren parlamenten
parteien haben die sich putin angedient
haben auch oft in prominenten positionen
wie in italien oder frankreich
ich glaube wir müssen erkennen dass wir
diesen kampf der werte
ernsthaft führen müssen und dass das
argument der jetzt geht es nur noch
geschäft und die werte sind uns egal
dass das am ende nicht nur für unsere
werte unsere institutionen unsere
sicherheit sondern auch für die
wirtschaft eine katastrophe war und ich
hoffe wir lernen wie sie lernen und wir
reagieren jetzt richtig denn wenn wir
das nicht tun dann ist die gefahr dass
putin diesen krieg den er uns erklärt
hat am ende auch noch gewinnen kann weil
er unsere im kern erschüttert und unsere
institutionen
fatale schwäche weil du bist vor ort wie
reagieren wir jetzt richtig seine
forderung an die deutsche politik
ich glaube dass wir durchaus auf einem
richtigen weg sind ich glaube dass es
noch schärfere sanktionen bräuchte das
ist weitere waffenlieferungen bräuchte
uns vor allem sozusagen
flugabwehrraketen abwehrmöglichkeiten
für die ukraine denn das ist das was
hier droht
gleichzeitig habe ich das gefühl dass
deutschland zumindest für die ukraine
keine wirklich große rolle momentan mehr
spielt wenn man sehr enttäuscht ist
von der regierung wenn man sehr
enttäuscht darüber das ist am anfang
sozusagen die ukraine gar nicht ernst
genommen wurde dass man gesagt hat ja
ach also in russland habt ihr keine
chance deswegen geben wir euch keine
waffen macht halt alleine und dann
gesagt hat ja aufgrund unserer
geschichte können wir das natürlich
nicht tun um ihr ukraine gesagt haben
moment mal auf eure geschichte müsstet
ihr ist doch gerade tun ja also das ist
das eine das zweite ist und das gehört
natürlich zur wahrheit dazu und das ist
auch das was ich hier erlebe in den
vergangenen stunden und in den
vergangenen tagen die frage wie schafft
man frieden weil das ist ja das was alle
leute sagen würden sofort wir wollen
nicht mehr tote wir wollen nicht mehr
kinder die sterben wir wollen nicht mehr
frauen die sterben wir wollen wir wollen
frieden in unserem land
und die ukraine ist glaube ich
tatsächlich zu vielen bereit aber wenn
wladimir putin bei dem bleibt was er
gesagt hat zu beginn des krieges nämlich
der ukraine die existenzberechtigung
abspricht
was soll ein land tun was würde
deutschland tun wenn ein großes land
kämen und sage deutschland gibt es
eigentlich gar nicht gehören zu uns
hermann ist die kann man dann sagen
alles noch etwas ergänzen
am morgen ist die ukraine zu recht
enttäuscht von deutschland
ich kann die enttäuschung verstehen weil
ich glaube mussten empathie für die
situation haben ihnen der die menschen
dort sind auch der präsident selbst und
von daher kann ich das sehr gut
verstehen die frage ist aber wenn der
realpolitik machen was ist sinnvoll zu
tun was nicht und es gibt ja drei
möglichkeiten nichts zu tun und ich
glaube das wäre wirklich völlig
unverantwortlich oder mit sanktionen auf
dieses verbrechen zu antworten das tun
wir oder militärisch einzugreifen
ein militärisches eingreifen ich glaube
dass es jedem hier bewusst würde die
gefahr einer gewaltigen eskalation in
sich bergen infolgedessen ist das was
deutschland jetzt tut auch was die
europäische union jetzt tut nämlich mit
sagen schon zu antworten auch wenn das
vielleicht nicht so wirksam ist wie wir
uns das wünschen würden das mittel der
wahl und wir können nicht jeden wunsch
von präsident seelands g erfüllen auch
wenn man ihn emotional völlig verstehen
kann man muss sich die verzweifelte
situation der menschen dort bewusst
machen ronzheimer ist glaube ich auch
deswegen so emotional auch das gar nicht
verstehen weil er das live miterlebt und
dann hat man eine spezielle sicht auf
die dinge das ist einfach so wenn man
wenn man das fürchterliche geschehen
dort hautnah miterlebt wenn man
unmittelbar betroffen ist dass man sagt
helft uns militärisch geht da rein aber
über der selbst in der wunde der kann
sich erklären wie er ist ja wird er aber
ich wäre definitiv gegen ein
militärisches ja nicht immer
unterbrechen das finde ich sehr
freundlich wir sehen ja das finde ich
nicht mehr gesehen
also ein militärisches eingreifen würde
ich für falsch halten und für ungemein
gefährlich halten nichtstun geht nicht
die sanktionen auch in der härte halte
ich für angezeigt und richtig paulis
unterbricht die ja nicht aber ich lass
dich darauf antwort nachdem schon
erklärt wurde wie du dich so verhält und
warum
ja ich glaube dass diese analyse zu
sagen weil jemand dinge sieht hat eine
besondere emotionalität die trifft
vielleicht zu aber ich kann sagen für
mich oder für bild wir haben da
eigentlich
2013 2014 eine sehr klare sicht auf
die dinge die hier passieren
ja ich habe gesehen wie auf der krim die
annexion passiert ist wie damals
schuldigen sie bitte aber die kfd das
mehr oder weniger bejubelt hat was dort
passierte und in den bars und gesagt hat
na ja das gehört ja schon wie zu
russland
und ich habe danach gesehen was in
diesem krieg passiert ist und ich habe
gesehen was menschen passiert ist die
neben gestanden die gestorben sind und
ich habe gesehen
wie putin dieses land auslöschen wollte
und will und dafür muss man glaube ich
gar nicht hier sein wo ich gerade bin in
kiel dafür kann man auch sehr nüchtern
und sicherlich vielleicht nicht so
emotional wie ich gerade
über die dinge nachdenken und dem lesen
und analysieren und dann kommt man zu
der genau gleichen erkenntnis dass das
was vladimir putin tut sehr sehr viele
jahre klar war und viele politiker wie
sie haben und auch andere politiker das
nicht sehen wollten dass das so kommen
würde und mir jetzt eine besondere
emotionalität zu unterstellen weil ich
hier bin geschenkt aber ich kann ihnen
sagen noch einmal wenn ich jetzt dort
ein studio wo ich ja auch schon ein paar
mal sah sitzen würde würde ich ihnen das
genauso sagen ich finde auch ein ganz
wichtiger aspekt um vielleicht also ich
kann emotionale täter nachvollziehen ich
wollte noch mal ein aspekt betonen in
der knaus gesagt hat die bedeutung von
bündnissen das ist ja auch etwas was wir
gestreift haben aber die bedeutung der
europäischen union auch wenn sie nicht
perfekt sein mag und die bedeutung der
nato ist glaube ich fielen in den
letzten wochen noch mal sehr sehr klar
geworden die sie vorher nicht so hatten
also wir haben ja jahrelang dafür
gekämpft dass zwei prozent ziel der nato
zum beispiel einzuhalten und das stieß
auf widerstand gegen waffenlieferungen
und vielleicht ist das auch ein punkt
der uns ein bisschen optimistisch
tatsächlich jetzt mit blick auf die
zukunft machen kann bei allen kolossalen
fehler in seiner vergangenheit ohne
zweifel passiert sind denn der
deutlichen mehrheit war immer gegen
waffenlieferungen jetzt ist eine
deutliche mehrheit dafür plötzlich ist
die spd dafür selbst jusos ich war
letztens auf einer solidaritäts demo mit
für die ukraine zusammen mit jusos die
hinter dem schild dann auch länger
liefen wir brauchen mehr
waffenlieferungen also das wäre vorher
undenkbar gewesen insoferne gewisser
wandel findet schon statt er ist
natürlich viel zu spät und sie haben ja
gefragt wie fühlen sich die ukraine und
das ist natürlich auch eine eine
emotionale und eine frage der empathie
manchmal wenn ich heute lese dass also
auf von ukrainischer seite der eindruck
entstand ist beim gespräch von präsident
selensky mit olaf scholz hätte die
ukrainische seite mit einer wand geredet
dann ist das eine ganz fatale eindruck
und nicht das signal was wir senden
sollten
ich glaube auch dass
extrem wichtig ist dass die deutsche
politik sich korrigiert das stimmt das
muss aber überall in europa passieren
also wir kommt fokussieren uns natürlich
jetzt hier aber ich habe die
italienische debatte verfolgt dort waren
von berlusconi bis zur salvini eine
ganze reihe von
regierungschefs extrem putin freundlich
ja mit dem urlaub gemacht haben ihn
verehrt haben gelobt
aber eben nicht aus irgendeinem
emotionalen effekt heraus sondern aus
der kühlen erkenntnisse die wir jetzt
gezogen haben putin und diese art von
regimen sind eine gefahr für unsere
eigene sicherheit das was in der ukraine
passiert ist wir hätten es als warnung
sehen müssen auch für unsere sicherheit
denn die deutsche sicherheit der
wohlstand die garantien die wir hatten
dass wir eben nicht nachdenken mussten
und ich verstehe dass es viele die
vielleicht auch nach ich die nächste
generation die nach den balkankriegen
groß geworden ist die hat keine kriege
in europa erlebt die konnte sich das
nicht vorstellen dass man militär
braucht das man robuste wehrhafte
institutionen braucht aber dass dieser
ihr dieser irrtum sollte jetzt
ausgeräumt sein wir sehen
ein vladimir putin und das war
eigentlich schon vor vielen jahren klar
ich war 2009 in moskau darunter waren
intellektuelle rund um den kreml die das
vorgezeichnet haben was was jetzt
passiert haben auch damals schon gesagt
wir akzeptieren den vormarsch der nato
nicht das war natürlich eine ausrede die
idee die ukraine hat 2014 ein
assoziierungsabkommen mit der eu
abschließen wollen für ihren wohlstand
weil sie gesehen hat was das bewirkt hat
in polen und rumänien
dem europäischen markt anzugehören das
wollten sie und das hat wladimir putin
versucht zu stoppen also es ging da nie
wirklich um die nato es ging auch nicht
um russisches sicherheit das war alles
vorgeschoben das problem war es gab zu
viele quer durch alle politischen lager
in vielen europäischen ländern die dann
diese russischen argumente putins
argumente denn es gab in russland immer
wieder stand und man muss auch daran
erinnern die vielen mutigen russen die
uns gewarnt haben wo sind sie heute ein
boris nemzow wurde in der nähe des
kremls erschossen andere
kasparow ist jetzt im exil viele es sind
im gefängnis nein herr sauer waren ja
der sich immer der immer gewarnt hat vor
putins gefahr nicht nur für russen und
russinnen sondern für europa ruft jetzt
vom gefängnis aber was für ein nudist
das vom gefängnis aus darf dazu auf zu
protestieren ich glaube wenn man das
sinken lässt wenn man das versteht wie
wie gefährlich das war dann glaube ich
entsteht auch der konsens ich bin da
auch optimistisch dass wir uns in die
richtung bewegen in deutschland und in
europa dass wir noch weiter gehen müssen
was die sanktionen betrifft dass wir
auch das risiko von wohlstands einbußen
zumindest kurzfristig eingehen müssen
weil wir am ende mehr verlieren wenn
wladimir putin weiterhin davon überzeugt
bleibt der westen ist schwach und
dekadent und kann sich nicht wehren und
ist zerstritten wir müssen zeigen dass
demokratien und demokraten und da ist
bleibt mir da ist wo leute mir sie
lenski ein modell für uns alle und ich
glaube deswegen ist auch so eine ich
eine ikone geworden ob er zum
europaparlament oder im englischen house
of commons spricht dass demokratie
verteidigt werden muss also jemand der
als schauspieler als als komiker in die
politik kommt er gewählt werden kann
beispiel für die großartige ukrainische
demokratie dass das möglich ist das war
ein heißes und denkens system für
deutschland ich glaube die tatsache dass
regierungen gewesen und abgewählt werden
können dass er leute aus der neu in die
politik kommen her dass jemand nicht wie
www putin
dafür ihr kind schon so sagt jürgen
klopp sollte bundeskanzler werden weil
die anlagen und eine these die gummis
für nein ich glaube dass das
entscheidende ist was man jetzt eben
selensky hat und die verteidigte jetzt
wo das mit erhard werte ich meine ein
beispiel der kontrast sich in moskau was
mir aufgefallen ist die besessenheit in
der russischen führung bei diesen ganzen
kreml intellektuellen gegen gegen lgbt
rechte die angriffe auf pride parade in
europa bevor wir dann jetzt es wird
jetzt neuer teamkollege alexander und
auch die hat im wahlkampf gesagt wir
sind für toleranz in der in der ukraine
und ich glaube dieser kontrast zwischen
der mut der zwischen werten und
pluralismus und jetzt muss man und das
ist das tragische jetzt müssen die
ukraine genau das nämlich ihr land ihre
demokratie ihre identität mit waffen
verteidigen und dabei ist sollte der
westen alles was verantwortlich
verantwortungsvoll gemacht werden kann
inklusive der lieferung von waffen
inklusive schärfere sanktionen machen
denn was hier am spiel steht sie in
unsere werte